cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below so i don't
have good news to start with today today
we we have to start talking seriously i
mean listen i could lie to you i could
come to you and say 2022 is looking
great for democrats it's looking great
for the left
but it's not 2022 is looking disastrous
and we're going to look at every data
point or most data points that we have
now and then i'm going to talk about
what could change the direction of 2022
but it it's not looking good democrats
are
if nothing changes and that's a key key
part of it if nothing changes democrats
are heading towards a possibly historic
crushing by republicans in the 2022
midterms now historically when one party
takes the white house in the immediate
first midterm it's not typically great
for that party so because joe biden took
the white house from a republican in
2020 we would expect it's not pointing
to being great
for democrats in 2022 but it's looking
particularly poor now there are some
democrats that are sounding the alarm
and it's angering some on the left even
if they're basically right in what
they're saying elizabeth warren is one
such democrat elizabeth warren now on
multiple shows appearing and saying
democrats are going to lose in 2022 if
we don't deliver more uh elizabeth
warren delivered a warning on sunday
saying if they don't get up and deliver
while their party has the majority they
will lose quote there's so much we can
do
and if we do it over the next 200 days
we're going to be in fine shape take it
to the people what we've done
i think we're going to be in real
trouble if we don't get up and deliver
then i believe that democrats are going
to lose now what she's saying kind of
like generically is fine
if we do stuff people like will win and
if we don't then we're going to lose but
she's increasingly using this language
because she sees the writing on the wall
and what is the writing on the wall well
every sign looks bad for democrats and
we can go through some of them first and
foremost how popular is joe biden now
there are some
headlines that say oh my god joe biden
in the low 30s approval
we look at an average of polling and if
you look at an average biden's approval
has ticked up just a hair from like 41
and a half to closer to 43 over the last
month but it's not good and we've looked
at these historical numbers before if
you compare joe biden to past presidents
he's now as unpopular as trump was at
this point in trump's presidency
he's less popular than obama he's less
popular than george w bush he's less
popular than clinton he's less popular
than george h.w bush
slightly less popular than reagan about
as popular as jimmy carter okay so we're
going back really far now to find a
president that at this point in their
first term was this unpopular in a sense
midterms are a referendum on the
president
whether they should be or not and so
that's not particularly good if you look
at a generic ballot
do voters want democrats or republicans
in pot in in congress
right now
republicans have about a two and a half
point advantage
in a generic ballot now the problem is
that because of gerrymandering which
favors republicans big picture at the
national level
this small advantage for republicans
which is growing a little bit by the way
might
significantly favor republicans when it
comes to the house because of
gerrymandering if we look at
predict it predict it is where you can
bet on different elements of politics
the question who will be speaker of the
house next congress which the speaker is
a member of the party that's in control
70 cents of every dollar is going behind
it being kevin mccarthy who will be
speaker of the house and then nine cents
is going to steve scalise both are
republicans meaning 79 cents of every
dollar in fact it's more because jim
jordan's getting five cents and donald
trump is getting four cents and elise
stefanik is getting three cents so 79
84
88
91 cents of every dollar are going to
it's going to be a republican speaker of
the house that's not good now betting
markets aren't polls but that's the
point betting markets are
where do i put my money
when it comes to what i think will
happen not what i want to happen
also on predicted what will be the
balance of power after 2022
75 cents of every dollar is going to it
will be both a republican house and
senate
um
so these these numbers are not looking
particularly good and then lastly the
politico forecast says the senate is
leaning republican whereas the house is
likely republican so this is very very
very bad now could everybody be wrong
well i think the question is could
things change between now and when the
people start voting which is in just a
few months but something has to happen
number one there's this old phrase it's
the economy stupid and when you and i if
we soberly look at the economy the
economy is actually doing okay yes
there's high inflation but it looks like
it's peaking and it will start to
decline gas prices have been high but
they're already starting to decline
unemployment we are very close to full
employment what about wages that's
always a question
but we are very close to full employment
if not there um the stock market very
shaky and it could be on its way to a
downturn but the stock market is still
nearly high uh historically high levels
most indicators are pretty good but
americans don't know it we just did a
story a couple weeks ago about a poll
where like a third of americans think
there have been job losses while joe
biden has been president there have been
dramatic job gains under biden now of
course you can always say are they
quality jobs and you can always ask
those questions but by the numbers we
typically accept
to look at
there have been massive job gains under
biden and a third of americans think
we've lost jobs so it's not the economy
it's the perception of the economy and
many americans think it's not so good
the one thing i do want to mention
the supreme court very soon could be
weeks at this could be four weeks could
be more like eight between four and
eight weeks from now the supreme court
is going to make a ruling about a state
abortion uh ban
and
if they uphold i believe it's the
mississippi law
it will effectively overturn roe v wade
which has been the law of the land
making abortion legal in most cases for
decades in the united states
it would be terrible if the supreme
court did that and i wonder
is that a catalyst that could really
motivate democratic voters to come out
and say we've got to do something about
this i don't want that to happen i want
the supreme court to make the right
decision but if they don't and they
effectively overturn roe v wade
what will that do
in terms of motivating democrats to say
well
i have to go and support whoever it is
at the state level governor senate
even if i don't think joe biden's been
fantastic because this is so important
women getting the right to decide for
themselves what they need to do
taken away
uh so that's a question mark i would
love to hear from you
what else could happen between now and
november that would change what are very
grim numbers for democrats let me know
what you think i mentioned in the last
segment the name kevin mccarthy there is
an unbelievable situation going on with
kevin mccarthy kevin mccarthy is the
house minority leader he's a republican
he republicans are in the minority for
now in the house and kevin mccarthy is
their leader now
it wouldn't be shocking because of what
we know
that people like liz cheney in the
aftermath of the january 6 riots were
talking about can we invoke the 25th
amendment to remove donald trump should
we demand that donald trump resign
that's liz cheney we know she doesn't
like trump
but kevin mccarthy is a guy who is the
uber trump loyalist
and reports started coming out last week
from the new york times that republican
house minority leader kevin mccarthy was
going around in the aftermath of the
trump riots saying trump should resign
trump should resign
in response to that report by the new
york times mccarthy denied the entire
thing and this is this is such a
brilliant series of events so new york
times reports that mccarthy denies it he
puts out a statement saying the new york
times reporting on me is totally false
and wrong
it comes as no surprise that the
corporate media is obsessed with doing
everything it can to further a liberal
agenda this promotional book tour is no
different if the reporters were
interested in truth why would they ask
for comment after the book was printed
the past year and a half have proven
that our country was better off when
trump was in the white house and rather
than address the real issues facing
americans the corporate media is more
concerned with profiting from
manufactured political intrigue from
politically motivated sources so he
denies that he ever said we gotta we
gotta look at trump resigning
and then
rachel maddow got the video
the audio i guess i should better say
after kevin mccarthy said oh no i never
said anything about trump should resign
audio of liz cheney speaking to kevin
mccarthy given to rachel maddow on msnbc
proves it is all true listen to this
conversation i'm here thanks kevin um
i guess there's a question when we were
talking about the 25th amendment
resolution um yeah and you asked if you
know what happens if it gets there after
he's gone is is there any chance are you
hearing that he might
resign is there any reason to think that
might happen
i've had some few discussions
my gut tells me no
i'm seriously
thinking of having that conversation
with him tonight okay that's kevin
mccarthy saying i'm thinking about
talking to trump about resigning tonight
he denied that this ever happened
here it is on tape i talked to him in a
couple days
from what i know of him i mean you guys
all know him too do you think he'd ever
back away but
what what i think i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna call him
my
this is what i think
no one will um the house
i think there's a chance you will pass
the senate even when he's gone
um
and
i think there's a lot of different
ramifications for that now i haven't had
a discussion
with them that if they did design with
it not happen so what i'm understanding
this is is
initially they were talking about the
25th amendment but that's something the
cabinet does my understanding is now
mccarthy is saying if he were to resign
would democrats agree not to impeach
that's my understanding of this part now
this is one personal fear i have
i do not want to get in any conversation
about
partying again i mean the only
discussion i would have with him
is that i think this will pass and it
will be my recommendation we should be
done
it would be my recommendation
that he should resign so just caught
caught mccarthy was lying he said i
never talked to trump about that uh but
i'm sorry he said i never said i was
going to talk to trump about that i
never said he should resign and there he
is on the recording saying i think he
should resign the reporters have even
more
check out this piece of an interview
from the rachel maddow show so just just
to underscore this just to be clear mr
mccarthy and his office have denied that
he said he was going to call trump and
tell him to resign you have it on tape
we just heard that he in fact said that
his also he's also today denied that he
called for members of his own caucus
other house republicans to have their
social media access cut off you've also
got that on tape
that's correct and we have a lot more on
tape from this period which is uh at the
highest levels of american politics it
is it is sensitive it's delicate uh and
it's high stakes and we have it all uh
on tape and
it's going to i think tell a very
different story about this period than
the story that many people are trying to
tell right now there's another recording
that they have where mccarthy says i've
had it with this guy speaking about
trump
all right i know this is not uh fun i
know this is not great i know this is
very tough but what i want to do
especially through here
is uh i don't want to rush things i want
everybody to have all the information
needed um
i i've had it with this guy
what he did is unacceptable
um
nobody can defend that and nobody should
defend it
okay
so that's pretty remarkable stuff now
eventually after all of the claims that
uh kevin mccarthy made about the new
york times article were refuted by audio
reporters finally got to mccarthy and
they said okay so like
they got you right and mccarthy shifts
the goal posts and he does it pretty
smoothly see if you can pick it up
congressman uh have you spoken with
president trump recently did you speak
with him last night i know i spoke to
him twice today i just spoke to him an
hour ago
how was your conversation uh did you
talk to him about uh the new york times
report and the conversation you had
about potentially asking him to resign
because the conversation here is what
they
for what they said we did we never did i
mean i never asked president trump to
resign uh we both talked about that
so this is the key point we don't even
need to watch the rest of the video
mccarthy goes
i never asked trump to resign now that
may well be true
but the claim initially was mccarthy
said trump should resign and mccarthy
denied it and he's on audio saying trump
should resign mccarthy wants to say
something different which is i never
asked trump to resign that's not what he
originally uh denied now does this make
republicans look better or worse
one perspective is this makes
republicans look better they're not that
crazy they saw how bad trump was and
they wanted him to resign
i say this makes them look worse because
what i understand is they saw how bad
trump was
and privately they knew that this guy
had to go and he was a danger but
publicly they insisted everything's fine
trump's great he's the greatest
president we support him they publicly
supported a guy that they knew was bad
for the country merely for their own
political benefit so i believe this
makes them look worse now last thing
it's great that this is coming out and
everything
but why
did it take a year for this stuff to
come out as usual it's the authors
holding stuff in order to sell books and
i understand why they're doing it i
understand the financial incentive but
for the country it would have been much
better if these tapes came out in real
time these conversations some of them
happened on january 10th i'm not saying
that if they came out on january 10th
maybe the reporters didn't have them on
january 10th but if instead of a year
later or more we knew in the moment that
republicans were saying trump should
resign
it actually might have pushed him to
resign i'm not saying it would have but
it would have at least had a shot and
now it's 15 months later 16 months later
and we're learning about it now that's
not new
that's how the business works
incredible stuff about kevin mccarthy
and
what else will we find out in the next
week send me your thoughts find me on
twitter at d pacman
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter i love this stuff cheese butter
is a delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years taste it for
yourself to really understand what it's
about
i don't think you'll be sorry and you'll
now get 20 off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below the david
pakman show is a viewer and listener
supported program we depend on the
membership program to fund our show many
of us who have cable subscriptions
unthinkingly give three four bucks every
month to fox news
just through our cable subscriptions i
would invite you consider a couple bucks
to the david pakman show by signing up
at joinpakman.com
and using the coupon code wow 22. back
in early march at the start of the
russian invasion of ukraine i did a
story called could putin be terminally
ill
and the story it garnered great interest
about a quarter of a million views on
youtube another similar number on
facebook and as i said at the time it
was a speculative story we're trying to
make sense of an invasion that appears
to make no sense vladimir putin's face
was pudgy could he be on steroids for
some medical condition could it be a
reason for rambling and aggression and
many of you agreed yeah i mean it
maybe it is but it remained quite
speculative there is now much more
pressing speculation about putin's
illness after a new video of vladimir
putin has been released
we have this video which we're putting
up on the screen this was a meeting that
putin had with his defense minister
sergey shoigu and in the video putin is
visibly gripping the table in front of
him apparently for support
um he looks pale
he looks bloated even more bloated than
he previously looked and he grips the
table for basically the entire 12-minute
video that was released by the kremlin
and the idea is that he's gripping it to
avoid some kind of tremor or shaking
from being visible but if you he's doing
this with his right hand if you look at
his left hand in the video
it is very shaky and moving around in
what some are describing as a kind of
unusual way it doesn't seem deliberate
putin's kind of hunched back on the seat
back and he's regularly tapping his toes
in a way which it might just be a tick
it could be indicative of something
parkinsonian it could be a side effect
from a medication professor eric busey
who's a body language expert from texas
tech university
said the face looks clearly bloated and
that there's a general unhealthy
appearance
and meanwhile the unconfirmed rumors
about putin being in treatment for
cancer continued to be published by
various media outlets they are not
confirmed but it's hard to argue at this
point that putin seems healthy now the
kremlin has denied allegations that
putin's health is a problem
but the speculation has included
prostate cancer
thyroid cancer parkinson's or something
parkinsonian
tardive dyskinesia is usually a side
effect of medication
uh wouldn't tell us the underlying
situation but it's something else that's
being mentioned now why does this matter
well it matters because circumstantially
this relates to the invasion of ukraine
in that if putin were very ill if putin
were terminally ill
it almost would be more sensible that he
might be trying to go out in a blaze of
erratic aggression meant to reconstitute
the soviet union and being seen as a
martyr for mother russia and as crazy as
that sounds
it makes more sense than just like
he decided to invade ukraine i mean it
makes no sense in in in a in thinking in
a logical way
uh now this is one of those you know
it's a low probability but high risk
event
if this is really what's going on if
this is an erratic unhinged putin on his
last leg as far as his life goes not his
political life and he thinks hey i'm
going to die soon
what's the downside to using nukes
if that's the state of mind that he's in
and again this is
speculative but it is fueling the
conversation again about our is anybody
thinking of an assassination attempt and
as i've said before
when we talk about
intelligence for high-level western
countries
they are
supposed to present all options and so
without saying anybody's thinking of
assassinating putin
it is without a doubt
that when intelligence had sit down with
heads of state
they give every option and so it is
almost a certainty that could it even be
done
when it comes to assassinating putin has
been discussed when we say all options
are presented they present all options
so newfound questions about vladimir
putin's health he doesn't look good will
we ever really know the truth
i have absolutely no idea
failed former president donald trump did
a rally this weekend in ohio
in support of vile republican candidate
for the senate jd vance now very often
when trump does these speeches we go
through the entire speech looking at
little bits and pieces i'm not going to
do that today today i want to take a
different approach i'm going to focus in
on two specific rants rants that only a
very delusional and unhinged person
would ever deliver now don't be confused
trump did all the normal stuff that he
does at these rallies he claimed he won
in 2020. he says socialists have taken
over the democratic party he says
mail-in ballots are fraud he did all of
that but i want to focus on two areas
that are so absurd that they're almost
comical i've told you before how donald
trump has seemed obsessed with water
pressure plumbing and toilets
and many of you think that that's a joke
but he really is
and he went on one such rant now i'm
gonna do something that i don't normally
do i'm going to play the whole toilet
rant for you together
just to give you a sense of how sick
this guy is stick with it it's minutes
long but that's the point here
this is what he's doing at a rally i
said we're going to do something about
it and we did that with many industries
but that one i went up to the whirlpool
factory where they make it and it was
incredible and that's
washers dryers all of that stuff the
dishwashers
and then we changed some rules too you
know i said what's the problem can we
help you well they don't give us any
water for the dishwasher what does that
mean
that we don't have enough water you know
what the ladies usually mostly the
ladies in some cases just to protect
myself as far as trump knows it's
usually women washing dishes in some
cases the men
okay
he'll say it was a terrible thing he
said he said only the ladies what no no
there's some men out there too they're
not so happy about it either
but in the dishwashers as an example
they had a little problem what was the
problem they didn't give you any water
and there was so little water that you
couldn't wash the dishes so what do
people do this is an issue trump knows a
lot about saying do it again do it again
do it again so by the time you do it 10
times the dishes are finally there
you've wasted a lot of electricity and
you spend more water than if you did it
right
so i had a regulation where i let you
have all the damn water you want for
your dishes now of course this is all a
lie like i have one of these you know
modern dishwashers that doesn't use a
lot of water i don't even have to scrape
the dishes i mean they just they come
out perfectly every time yes
and the same thing for your clothing
same thing for your clothing for your
dish
for your dishwasher is great but for
your washes and dryers
and the washers they had no water coming
out and i just asked these simple
questions to the head of whirlpool who
the hell knows better than him
i said you have a problem yeah the
problem is
there's not enough water i also did it
by the way
for your sinks you ever go to a new home
you buy a nice new home because of the
trump policies hopes were going up like
crazy
by the way hate to tell you the stock
market dropped over a thousand points
free association of ideas all over the
place but he eventually gets back to his
favorite which is toilets on friday
lots of luck everybody
but you ever go into a new home and you
turn on the faucet and there's no water
comes out they have restrictions and you
know we're talking about places you
don't have a water problem a lot of say
most states don't have a water problem
in fact you do have a water problem you
have too much water you don't know what
to do with it so they have restrictors
so you're sitting there washing your
hands and it'll come on water come out
baby i want to wash i have to tell you
if this guy hadn't been president of the
united states like in a normal country
where this guy wouldn't be elected this
would actually be hilarious like this is
hilarious but they made this guy
president i got rid of it
same thing with showers i'd go into a
shower
and i'd go to a hotel that was new and i
said i can't stay in these places why
the water just drips out a little bit
slowly i want to take good care of my
hair
i don't want that no it's true
i mean i put the soap in it takes you 20
minutes to have the water come out to
get the damn soap out of your hair
but uh
and i won't talk about the third element
of the bathroom because every time i do
the fake news only talks about yep he
when he when he goes his real passion is
toilets and flushing them 10 to 15 times
but he gets punished when he talks about
it
but you know what i'm talking about
one time two times five times ten times
no water comes out so
can anybody in the audience tell me if
you've had to flush a toilet ten times i
mean really you know in all honesty
trump is obsessed with this and i don't
know what he's flushing we know
sometimes he flushes secret documents
maybe that's why he's flushing ten times
i
totally
took that out and we
made it so that when you have a sink you
can actually wash your hands normally
and you can take a shower
and you can do that other thing normally
right the third element of the bathroom
so we did it with the dryers we did so
guys this it's insane it's a
three-minute rant about plumbing
then trump unprovoked brings up the
dementia test okay starts out of thin
air there's no rhyme or reason and again
we're doing this a little differently
this is the full dementia rant and lis
he's bragging about it it's he thinks
it's an iq test it's just meant to
screen for serious dementia dr ronnie
and many doctors
and i aced it and you know now they
don't call me stupid they say he's a
dictator he wants to take over the world
you know they used to call me jd uh they
made they said maybe stupid so i said
to doc ronnie you know doc ronnie is now
a great congressman in texas great very
popular guy i think he won by like 52
points or something right but he's now a
great congressman i said ronnie
i don't like when people call me stupid
i had great heritage an uncle who was a
great great genius by the way great
heritage i guess trump thinks he's
predisposed to be smart because his
uncle was smart as a weird heritage
it's almost like saying he had good
blood father who is a genius everybody
they're all we have a lot of geniuses i
don't like being called stupid is there
a test or something i can take to prove
to these radical left maniacs yeah the
test would maybe be an iq test even
though that's questionable not just a
dementia screening that i'm much smarter
than them is there a test and he said
sir there is a test it's called a x test
i said what's it like he said well it's
uh it gets very tough the first
questions are easy
and the middle of the test gets tough
and now we all know it doesn't get tough
we went we've gone through the test it's
the montreal cognitive assessment the
test is quite tough sir actually
i said well
what happens if i don't do well
he said well you know it's uh it's at
this great hospital you know our great
military hospital we all know our
military hospital and the system is
incredible incredible doctor so i said
walter reed i said
uh
by the way it's just a piece of paper
you don't even really need to go to a
hospital to take this test it's just
it's a single piece of paper
let me take it he said sir here's the
problem if you don't do well everyone's
going to be reading about it at the
front pages now of course that's not
true because they would if he didn't do
well they would just never talk about it
they said and i if i do do well nobody's
going to talk about it that's the way it
works with the fake news they don't talk
about it
so i said he said and other people are
present while you're taking it sir
i said let's go dr ronnie give me that
goddamn test right
i want to take that test
give me that test stock running
so they gave it to me and they started
asking questions and some you know
around the third or fourth or fifth
question sir
sir
name five things
they named five things a light
a group of people now trump here is
struggling to even do it but he's
actually struggling
ohio
a fake teleprompter that i never end up
using
[Laughter]
and the fake news
thank you sir very much thank you then
they come back to you 20 minutes later
name the five things you named
and i hid it perfectly that's pretty
tough it's like a hole-in-one in golf
it's really tough to do they say nobody
hits that one and when we told that you
know we told it on fox i hope fox gets
all straightened out all right i can't i
really can't do anymore um
bragging about a dementia test and
saying it makes them really really smart
so a bizarre rally one more clip there
were the normal glitches here is trump
struggling to say dropbox
no more
by the drop boxes are just so bad no
more all right so listen this is a guy
who if he was not president at one point
would be hilarious this would be
absolutely hilarious it would almost be
it would almost be lovably hilarious my
dementia test and i'm mad about flushing
toilets
he was president
and he was using those toilets to flush
secret documents and it is absolutely
horrifying
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
as i've said many times before if there
are no cultists there really is no cult
it's just a guy screaming things that
don't make sense and nobody's paying
attention and the united in the united
states right now
the level of cultists that has pervaded
the american right wing is getting to
such a degree
that even cult isn't appropriate because
cults are usually kind of small and
unfortunately a big part of the modern
republican party has been taken over by
anti-empirical
anti-science in some cases paranoid
delusions that we would ordinarily say
if they replaced god
with some other word or they replaced a
republican with some other random person
we would say oh you need help you're in
a cult we need to get you out and we're
going to look at some examples of that
right now this is very interesting we've
spoken before about this group blacks
for trump
and one of the questions we had about
the group was does the group really
exist because they have
almost no online presence other than one
very strange website and blacks for
trump is a group that often would show
up at trump rallies and on the stage you
would see like over trump's shoulder
there would be like a strategically
placed blacks for trump person with the
shirt and everything often they would be
gone before the end of the speech well
at trump's rally in delaware ohio over
the weekend right side broadcasting
actually interviewed one of these people
from blacks for trump and it's
completely unintelligible the guy is
like really close to the interviewer and
keeps touching him everything about this
is bizarre but finally we have actual an
interview with one of these members of
blacks for trump check this out hey
a person that comes to your aid helps
you all the time and then when he really
wants to come to your aid
suddenly
he's a racist when he was the first one
to say that black people matter to him
he said it directly to me i'm sorry
about that
he said it directly to me and in the um
i forgot not joseph kaderson but uh
miami knights but he's done so much for
the for the black community and sir he
did so much for the black community
right
so there is blacks for trump making a
point about something of just a very
strange situation then we move on to a
woman at the trump rally who explains
that she believes princess diana and
jackie onassis are still alive and tries
to pull the interviewer into it
it is um i mean listen it's i i know we
always say well dave is it we can't
diagnose but
something is very wrong with these folks
okay first of all y'all are
so cute i love the outfits i would like
detailed explanations on every single
shirt ready set go right so
living
living and we know living
rule in the world
and you don't take down evil by being
quiet or silent right so people need to
understand who they are do they look
like them today no
you think you think princess diana is
still alive absolutely 100 percent do
you
i didn't but maybe maybe you have
something to that you know that i don't
know well you know god speaks to us
right right there's ways that they can
agree on he can figure these things out
so people start learning abc one two
three which michael jackson talked about
how many years ago right he sung about
so when people start understanding
gematria they start understanding the
numbers a equals one b equals two c
equals three
yeah pretty open and shut case now if
you're wondering what gematria is
gematria is is hebrew numerology using
the the hebrew alphabet or as it's known
the aleph bet
um where you just you're basically it's
like what you did as a kid when you make
a code and you i'm gonna write you a
note and like a is gonna be one and d
will be four and that type of thing
it's just it's it's hebrew numerology
and
in my experience now i don't wanna i'm
sure there are scholars somewhere that
would be exceptions to this
i have never in my life heard anyone use
the word gematria or gematria
seriously
and they weren't completely out of their
minds
maybe there's a counterexample but i'm
certainly not uh not aware of one here's
a woman
complaining about critical race theory
obviously she doesn't know what it is
like forget that ship has sailed it's
not even reasonable to expect them to
know what it is at this point she
doesn't know what it is but it sounds
like she says her kids go to private
school where like they don't even teach
whatever she thinks of as critical race
theory it's really weird but she's very
upset well private school private
private clear fork yeah private so i was
gonna say as a parent what's your
thoughts on what's going on or the
indoctrination of our kids with some of
their crt and some of the other really
radical things yeah it is really
stressful i mean the things she's really
stressed i mean her kids go to a private
school so it's not a problem but it's
really stressful but they're trying to
teach kids these days it's just not
right
you know if if it goes against god's
word then it's wrong
without a doubt it should be as simple
as that yeah now of course there is
separation of church and state in public
schools and so really god's word should
have no role to play whatsoever but
very very angry people about things
which they don't understand and they
don't and they aren't affected by
uh but there it is here's a woman at the
trump rally who said she had 10 trump
flags on her on her porch
and the host volunteers that it's
unamerican
not to have
flags okay
yeah we've talked to them earlier about
hanging flags let me ask you a question
in your neighborhood that you guys live
in your work whatever trump's flag's
still flying oh absolutely oh yeah yeah
you haven't seen my front yard
never went down
my porch
this is literal cultishness this is you
are you are signaling your devotion
you're signaling your devotion in some
cults right the way you signal your
devotion is the leader gets to have sex
with whoever they want right so you look
at the jim jones cult
you look at the charles manson called
that was a big thing you signal your
devotion by it was a bunch of stuff you
don't question what the leader tells you
and you're available to the leader
for sex whenever here the way they
signal their devotion is we never took
down our flags
we kept the trump flags up the entire
time and we said if you want to find our
house look for the house flags right we
have tan flags on our porch
yes
i just did a promo for mypillow.com and
mystore.com because i said if you have
if you don't have a flag in front of
your house hang on a second you know
what you're saying i'm un-american right
put a flag in your front yard you have
to they demand compliance you must have
the signal that you are a member of the
team here's one guy who says that trump
rallies are better than grateful dead
shows i tell all my friends i've seen
jerry garcia 129 times in concert it's
better than any grateful dead show and
it smells a lot better
go charm yeah so listen these folks at
least in theory they could be your kid's
orthodontist they could be your kid's
teacher they might be the person fixing
your car or whatever right these these
folks really are everywhere uh and i
don't know how we deprogram them one
last bonus clip
the there are opening prayers at these
trump events and the prayers are getting
more and more cult-like they're praying
in thanks
for trump for life and and we we're
grateful for the living
legacy of president donald john trump we
thank you for his willingness to
continue to organize and to travel
across our nation delivering the message
of freedom and to remind us you and me
that we play a critical part in saving
our nation we thank you o god
for the clarity of purpose you have
given to president trump so i think you
get it um jamie raskin member of
congress he says he has started reading
about cults and consulting cult experts
just for help on how to communicate with
his republican colleagues in the house
of representatives that's how bad it has
gotten
and i don't know how we teach our way
out of it i don't know how we educate
our way out of it i really don't it's as
depressing as i could possibly imagine
uh mike pillow the ceo and founder of my
pillow mike lindell
he was also at the trump rally this is
the last element of the trump rally
we're going to look at today
he arrived in ohio for the rally he was
completely out of breath
and he again seems to be talking about
lawsuits against machines remember he
wants to sue every machine we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah i actually
um i have a computer monitor that has
gone into witness protection because it
is very much afraid of this pillow
lawsuit listen to this guy
yesterday was a historical day in
history the history of america well yeah
i mean every day is historical that's
true uh we filed the first
preliminary injunction in the state of
arizona to get rid of the machines once
and for all
and that's the first of many many i want
to do all 50 carrie lake and uh
mark fincham we're the plaintiffs
and uh
the defendant is katie hobbs the
secretary of state and their maricopa
county and pima county county
commissioners and staff and our
commissioners i think there
and uh this is so important because yeah
it's it really sounds like any day now
they're gonna put trump uh back in
office this guy has a following
trump praises him at every single one of
his rallies here he is
uh talking about the masks on planes
coming off have really reinvigorated a
lot of people um all the other judges
how would you like to been a judge back
then have been the first one to step
forward and have your family attacked or
whatever yeah they lived in fear but now
since we all know the evidence is there
and everything the judges are going to
be brave remember that donald trump
appointed over i think there's almost
500 judges look at what one just did
down in florida was that amazing they
ordered the mask gone on the airplanes
it's beautiful you know it's just one
judge to say judge should change the
court
and this is what's going to happen with
these preliminary injunctions the judges
are going to start pouring it on saying
we can't have these corrupt machines
where you know when a country when
you're in a country
and machines that must be it by why
can't he
he out of breath voliminary a junction
uh it's it's all bizarre here he claims
trump really won ohio by 3.4 million
which would be an extra half million
votes for trump where did those come
from we don't know in the in this great
state of ohio
the big lie which is the big lie they
say donald trump won by 475 000 votes
in with your machines and with
everything went on you guys had
supposedly pretty good voting rolls well
that's not true dr frank went over all
your stuff but uh by the way for people
listening the reason pillow's screaming
is there's like a crowd that has kind of
gathered to listen to him in the state
of ohio donald trump really won three
million four hundred thousand to two
million four hundred and thirty thousand
that's another five hundred thousand
votes that were stolen so that's
completely made up and then lastly here
is pillow actually addressing the rally
crowd and here he says we've got to get
back to god we're living in the greatest
time in history because everything's
getting revealed when we get through
this it's going to be the most beautiful
place we're going to have fair elections
we're going to put god back in our
schools and we will once again be one
nation under god we're living and of
course putting god back into schools
would go completely against the
constitution of the united states in
separation of church and states so this
man is a hero
in a normal timeline and a normal
universe
nobody would ever have voted for trump
and people like pillow would never be
revered as heroes but alas we are not in
normal times and these are the heroes
that the right wing cult has
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com davidpakmanshow where
you can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show one of the things that
some republicans have realized they've
come to understand this is that they
have sort of lost control
of the monster
they created and thought would be a
great thing for them and that monster is
the trumpists in the republican party
kevin mccarthy caught on audio we now
know we talked about it earlier in the
show back in january of 2021 saying we
trump should resign trump should resign
he realized that they lost control they
were gonna ride the monster oh look at
the they're gonna vote they're voting
for trump i guess i guess we're gonna
have a republican president they're
let's go with it they're willing to vote
for trump
and then they became a monster they lost
control of and they rioted on january 6
then the rest is sort of history we've
also seen them lose control of the
monster when it comes to vaccines and
donald trump recently gave a speech on
amelia in in on amelia island in florida
and he wanted to praise the vaccine and
take credit for it but he knows
that his base might crush him and he
acknowledges
sometimes people get angry when i talk
about the vaccine our greatest
achievements was
getting the vaccine done in nine months
instead of five and a half to twelve
years but
the problem is you know we saved tens of
millions of lives all over the world but
i can't talk about it because our base
our beautiful base of which some of you
are there you get angry when we mention
the word vaccine don't get it true
we did it in nine months less than nine
months right
less than nine months
trump wants
his base
to be skeptical of science when it's
politically inconvenient whatever it
might be masks public safety guidelines
whatever don't take unproven stuff for
kovid
but when it's to his benefit he wants
them to believe in that very science
that he has primed them not to believe
believe in science when it makes me look
good and this is not a new thing trump
knows he's ruined his own base back in
august of 2021
trump actually got booed when he talked
about the vaccine and how great it is
three days less than nine months and
it's great and you know what i believe
totally in your freedoms i do agree you
got to do what you have to do but
i recommend taking the vaccines i did it
it's good take the vaccines but
you got no that's okay that's all right
you got your freedoms
but i happen to take the vaccine
if it doesn't work you'll be the first
to know okay
i'll call up alabama and say hey you
know what
but so regularly getting booed then he
did this weird thing with bill o'reilly
where there were often unsold seats and
they both said they got the vaccine and
people didn't like it both the president
and i are vacs and uh did you get the
booster
yes i got it too okay so uh don't don't
don't don't don't no none
that's all this is a very tiny group of
trump wanting to minimize the booing but
it was certainly there and then lastly
uh from this very strange speech just
one this is just funny because of what
it points to for the next few years
here's how trump says we're going to
unite the country the one that we have
the path back to american unity is not
to surrender the culture wars the path
back to national unity is to decisively
win
the culture wars now of course the idea
that you're going to unite the country
by winning imaginary culture wars that
you created in order to divide the
country is absurd it is absurd but
i don't think republicans have any other
idea so if i had to guess in 22 and in
24
their platform will be no we're not
going to fix climate we're not going to
fix health care we're not going to fix
immigration we're not going to fix taxes
we're not going to fix anything we're
just going to win imaginary culture wars
that we created and then say hey we put
out a fire we started sort of except
it's still on fire and you should vote
for us thanks to that they're telling us
what the strategy will be and i believe
them i don't want to spend a lot of time
on this but i do want to let you know
that this guy christopher key who is now
known for injecting urine for kovid he's
been arrested this is the guy who i
previously told you
was recommending people drink urine
and then last week started recommending
people inject urine he
has been arrested organizers tasked with
putting on a jacksonville florida
conference headlined by coveted truthers
robert malone and peter mccullough had
enough of anti-vaxxer christopher key's
shenanigans they reported the vaccine
police leader to police as a trespasser
which sent him back to jail
again where he is now awaiting a
preliminary hearing
key could be heard on video berating an
organizer of the far-right gathering
after he claimed that she mandated he
moved his car off a
i
sideway is that a sidewalk is that the same
thing then he claimed he went to the
building at the take action for freedom
tour to take a tinkle and that led to
police being called he said he was being
asked to leave
um an unidentified gathering organizer
said to the officer that key was causing
a disturbance you've caused a big
disturbance
he apparently still wouldn't leave after
being given a trespass warning and then
he was indeed arrested now what's
fascinating is he wasn't arrested for
injecting urine that apparently is legal
as long as you do it to yourself i guess
i mean it's not a good idea it's
dangerous if you hit it if you hit a
vein
uh it can be very very bad
but just trespassing and again what is
fascinating to me about this stuff is
i've said before you look at flat earth
you put two flat earthers in a room
together they both agree the earth is
flat
but for conflicting reasons one will say
well here's the proof that the earth is
flat and the other will say no that
can't be true because here's my proof
and it directly conflicts with it
these
anti-vax and sort of like covet
alternative treatment people
they are often in conflict about why the
vaccines are bad or about what you
should do instead and you've got a big
group of people who talks about zinc and
ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine etc
they don't want anybody injecting urine
they agree the vaccines are bad but
they're like inject urine no that
doesn't make any sense then you've got
the drink and nebulize and inject urine
people who are like zinc no way in hell
zinc some
heavy metal poison who the hell knows uh
they conflict with each other these
people are all bonkers they're still
holding conferences but it's at least
funny that christopher key ended up
getting himself arrested maybe for
attention but i don't really know what
the end game is if he's trying to get
attention
we have a voicemail number that number
is
to david p
last week i said
i don't think it's a great idea for
bernie to run again
i gave my reasons why as a bernie
supporter myself in 2016 and 2020
98 of the reactions from the audience
were substantive and respectful
two percent of the reactions were people
calling me all sorts of names because i
thought i i think bernie's time has come
and gone he'd be
88 years old at the end of his term i
don't think it makes sense
um but here's a question that i think is
a good one which came up in response
take a listen
hey david
kyle from florida here uh i really liked
your take about bernie
not running or running potentially in
2024
i was just curious
who
would you
like to see running if not bernie okay
um that's the one thing i'm curious
about is
is who could uh take up that mantle so
to speak
um so yeah i do like your take there i
think that
you make a lot of good points um
although we agree on a lot of things he
might not be the
person anymore for the moment all right
so listen this is a good question who
who who am i interested in for 2024
i am not
i'm gonna give you some names right now
i am not telling you that i agree with
every one of these people's politics
more than i agree with bernie's i'm just
giving names of people that i think are
interesting
and bring the energy i would like to see
these are people of varying political
orientations some of them because of
identity issues i don't know if they
would really do well but here's just
people i think are interesting and are
smart and bring good energy and they're
not in any particular order congressman
jamie raskin i think is excellent i
think he's brilliant he actually is a
progressive activist you look at his
background and he's a progressive
activist that's where he comes from
he is very well spoken
uh and brings some good energy that's
one person that i think is interesting
katie porter the democratic
congresswoman i know a lot of people say
david does she have the experience or
would people vote for her i'm just
saying i really like katie porter's
energy and i think she's super smart
excellent in adversarial and debate type
situations i think katie porter is a
rising star in the democratic party
georgia senator john ossoff very young
guy
i love his energy i think he's brilliant
i think he's a fantastic speaker
interesting guy
pete bootage do i love pete's politics
exactly no he's to my he's to my right
there's no question about that
but he is so good
when he goes on with adversarial media
he's good at succinctly and pointedly
de-arming
disarming i guess we would say and
delegitimizing right-wing arguments i
would love to see what he would do in a
in a more prominent position and then i
think i think stacy abrams is super
interesting and i think that she's
extremely
smart and well-spoken as well like many
of these uh other people so those are
five democrats that i think are
interesting that bring more the energy
that i want to see
with a range of different backgrounds
and experiences and identities so those
are just five ideas
and i'm not saying they would win a
primary uh they they all have reasons
why we might say well they're not like
your typical
fast-track democratic primary candidate
but those are five names i'm interested
in we have a great bonus show for you
today
the french people have re-elected their
president emmanuel macron
and
that's good but at the same time it was
much closer this time with marine le pen
and we're going to talk about that on
the bonus show
senator former senator orrin hatch the
longest-serving republican senator has
passed away at the age of 88 we will
talk about his legacy and twitter has
banned ads that deny climate change are
people going nuts of course free speech
first amendment etc we will talk about
it all on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com you'll get instant
access to the bonus show
lots of other great perks and you'll get
the show every day six hours before
everybody else
sign up at joinpacman.com and we will
see you on the bowman show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutter.com
the link is down below